in downtown bamako malians are absorbing
the news the elections they were
promised next month aren't going to
happen and may not for up to five years
opposition leaders say the decision by
the transitional government is
unacceptable
holding meetings to say they want to be
in power for five years i think this is
anti-constitutional anti-democratic and
it hasn't got any legitimacy
was sworn in last july following two
military coups in less than a year he
sought to unite malians and said
presidential elections would be held
but on thursday a conference charged
with recommending an election timetable
said the polls should be delayed by
between six months and five years
goethe's supporters agree now is not the
time for elections
post-electoral crises are more dangerous
than the situation we're in today
because we've seen genocides we've seen
bloodbaths across the world
today i think we need calm to reassure
the population here and elsewhere
the international community must
understand that the lesser evil today is
addressing the concerns of malians
despite criticism of the interim
government analysts say it has managed
to bring some stability to mali the
government in bamako is is
to a large extent a step ahead of every
everyone you just have to look at how
they've been able to change the reality
on the ground in a very incremental but
very steady
basis the west african regional block
ecowas is expected to discuss the
situation next week it's already imposed
sanctions on officials and has promised
more if mali's leaders don't produce a
plan for a democratic transition
victoria gatenby al jazeera